there was another article i want to
touch on here related to that it said
moms who went through coveted breakups
say solo parenting is much easier
rolled my eyes rolled my eyes okay first
of all i want to know who who said this
and what their finances look like
did they
break up with their partner because
during the pandemic you know we were all
home right so you realized okay this
person drives me crazy 24 hours a day in
my fate you know there were moments like
that everybody had them everybody had
them
so did they break up with their partner
and then they had enough money that they
went and hired a nanny that came and
basically stands in for their partner
doing like all that extra stuff and
money wasn't an issue so they didn't
need financial help what's going on
there
this is a very dangerous message to send
out there there are women
oftentimes it's women although there are
single dads too we have to acknowledge
that there are dads that are single out
there doing an incredible job there are
people that find them themselves in less
than ideal circumstances it happens
there are deaths involved
horrible but it happens there are
separations there's betrayals that
happen there are things that happen that
force couples to separate and you have
single parents sometimes there's a
substance abuse issue a
violence issue i mean there's many
things that go on that force someone to
have to raise a child alone
that's not ideal that's not to be
championed
that's not easy you when you lose a body
when you lose an income when you lose a
pair of arms when you lose a support
system
your life gets harder
now maybe these are people that have an
extended family where and can you know
great finances and
for whatever reason they inherited a
bunch of money and they got you know two
au pairs in the house i mean i don't
know what their situation is but this is
not the norm and i certainly don't want
to see a message going out to people
like oh don't worry you and your husband
didn't get along during the pandemic
when you were in each other faces all
day you can do it alone and be happier
it's way easier
again that's a very privileged statement
that
is really unfair to the reality of what
a lot of single parents face
and even though single parents just you
know let me say this they find
themselves in a situation that's not
ideal they do many of them do an
incredible job
do the very very best they can to raise
amazing children
so credit to you all who find yourself
in that position
but you know it's not ideal and you know
it was hard and you know it was a
struggle and you know resources
sometimes maybe were tight
for the average person and you know that
it wasn't always easy to find help and
maybe your mom and dad moved closer to
you whatever it may have been stop
glorifying this stuff and making it like
oh this reminds me of that you don't
need a man
you don't need a man you can do just go
to remember that video the other day go
to the sperm bank just go to the sperm
bank you don't need to admit right
because kids don't need fathers because
fathers don't play an integral role in a
house
that girl's gonna let me tell you she
decides to do that oh i'm just gonna
have baby i'm just gonna go to the sperm
bank unless she's sitting on a lot of
cash
and you know a family that can fill a
farm
she better be prepared even when in my
house my kid gets sick
you know gets a cold whatever
that is an extremely challenging
circumstance if you don't have somebody
else in the house
you know hey jeremy can you take him for
two seconds i want to hey we go to a
doctor's appointment you're sharing in
all those experience you also have
somebody to bounce off of when you get
nervous oh hartley runs a fever i'm like
i start to panic you know my husband's
very measured and very calm in almost
any situation that balance is so
important don't take away the from the
hardships these people who find
themselves in these situations struggle
and and and survive and come out on top
and raise amazing children oftentimes
don't don't demean their struggle by
saying oh it's easier to just do it
yourself what a privileged ridiculous
thing to say if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
[Music]